long time red sox fan ian anderson the
pride of
new york made his second big league
start against boston and faces them for
the first time this year tonight yeah
see those 12 starts this season
four and three 69 case bonus in 213
first time face in boston last year in
boston chip his second start six innings
and only two runs in a win
lying out to short down to a knee dansby
swanson stabs the line out
and one down here in the first inning
and boston a
very prolific first inning scoring team
has two in scoring position with one out
xander bogarts hit a home run in game
one yesterday
they struck him out big first strikeout
for ian anderson his 70th of the season
and they're two men out ian anderson is
one out away from getting out of the
inning
without any trouble trouble with that is
he's got to go through rafael devers
he takes high ball four fast block the
fastball except for that one breaking
ball that crossed up his catcher and he
didn't
mind walking raffy it appeared on a
renfrew up nightingale 258
three on two out the pitch and a
basement into right field
not crushed but verdugo is in
here comes martinez he scores
red sox lead at two to nothing well they
play that shift he hit that ball below
the trademark almost off the thumbs and
muscled it
on a soft line and hit on the dirt
not barking where a second baseman
normally plays it went on
into right field for a two run single
two nothing red sox so they do cash in
on this opportunity
garrett richards who's four and four
with a 409
era for boston yeah threw up against the
braves a while back he's had
two starts he's going well with the two
three one opponents are hit
362 in the first inning with 12 runs
against him
and all five of his home runs have come
in the first 25 pitches of a game
very fortunate still have a two-nothing
lead with two down now and here comes
austin reilly swinging a high fly
shallow right field it's there for
renfro and he
makes the catch to retire the side so
the braves get the first two men
on but richards is very good at escaping
jams gets out of this one
it'll be dalbeck richards and gonzalez
for boston here in the second
swung on and missed got him with a
fastball garrett richards in the
right-hand banners box
there's strike three parksdale rings up
richards back-to-back strikeouts
that'll take care of him fastball
freezes marvin gonzalez
and ian picks up his fourth strike out
of the ball game i just love that you
get a crack at it with a cunha and two
men on base yeah
ronald with a double in the first inning
extended his on-base streak to 24 games
and he swings and it's a high fly right
center field it's dave back goes renfro
has the room makes the catch
but that was scary because that's the
way the wind is blowing tonight and
they spray him two matt now in the hands
of almonte runner third one out
he stings one of the air out towards
left center field verdugo racing over to
the gap he'll run it down
now that is plenty deep enough to drive
in freddie freeman
rbi number four for almante it's now a
2-1 lead for boston
as the braves pick up their first run of
the ballgame here in the third inning
and renfro to third with one down bobby
dalbeck struck out his first time up
swinging a hard ground ball to the left
side in the left field a base hit they
had the infield pulled in and bobby
shot it right through the 5.5 hole
renfro scores its 3-1
red sox now you put it in play everybody
in
field in quickly gets by and this is
normally just a ground ball up the
middle i don't know
where they'd be playing but they're
playing in it's an easy base hit
contact infield's in they're playing the
pull
nicely done gets the third run in so a
runner at first one out for garrett
richards well not square he swings and
lines one into the gap in right center
field
this is extra bases dulbeck to third
he gets the wave home it's an rbi
double for the pitcher richards and the
red
sox leaded four to one no lambo here man
i'm going
how about that first career rbi for
garrett richards and he helps himself
that'll put runners at first and third
for the braves he connects and it's a
ground ball
diving attempt by gonzalez knocks it
down pops up throws over the doll back
and they get the out but it scores
dansby swanson ander and ciarte hit one
hard and a good play by marwan gonzalez
at second base to get the out
a 4-2 lead for the red sox for the
bottom of the fourth inning runners at
first and second two down
and the reigning national league mvp in
the box round ball right side might find
a hole pass to diving marlon gonzalez
and a base hit
over running it is renfro horadio will
score
throwing on the brakes at third base as
acuna freeman picks up an rbi
and it's now a one-run ball game it's
4-3
even with gonzalez playing out in
shallow right field he couldn't go to
his right and knock that down
and i thought for a second when renfro
overran it
and ron washington may send to kunya but
the ball didn't roll far enough away
from renfro
to take advantage and lead off single in
the fifth
in front of xander bogarts a strikeout
into double tonight
and that's going to be a fair ball down
the line he's done it again
martinez racing into third he's coming
around
it's a bad throw and he will score
without even having to slide play at
third
he's safe took almonte a while to get to
the ball
down the left field line bogarts with
two seeing eye doubles in as many trips
he takes third on the overthrow and
picks up an rbi and the red sox back to
a two-run lead
and it's five to three red sox runner at
third nobody out infield in
devers has walked and fouled out shot
right past swanson and another run home
hot one by endeavors red sox lead at 6-3
rafael was 55th
rbi red sox keep answering you know
atlanta scores
they score right back at you runners at
first and second nobody out and dansby
swanson the battery he has struck out
he has tripled and he has scored a run
on hit deep to left that's got a shot
that's a line drive home run tiger
dansby swanson with a 370 foot
laser right above the bullpen
of the red sox down the left-field line
and that will end the night
for garrett richards just like last
night
the braves come all the way back and tie
the game this time in the fifth
freddy's reached three times he's walked
he's singled home a run he's reached on
an e7
in the air left center field did he get
enough at the track
at the wall it's gone freddie freeman
is back he puts the braves in front
7-6 with an opposite field
homer that is vintage freddie freeman
aj minter gets the call out of the
bullpen he inherits bases loaded two out
as christian arroyo will pinch in
look at this baby go that's a grand slam
and the red sox leaded ten to
seven did you believe it a
hanging breaking ball a one-two pitch
boy christian arrows that's a huge hit
this season this week alone
a game tying three-run homer in
consecutive nights
and now a go-ahead slam in the seventh
in atlanta
graves do have a base runner with one
away avino looking to get
acuna junior swings and drives one to
right center and deep long run renfrew
he
what are you doing thank you what a gift
freeman would have been the tying run
now no chance
he's out trying to make strike three and
it's over the red sox sweep the series
they win this marathon
ten to eight